yay hello welcome to our monday evening
evening show it's evening at least here
on my end yeah all of you are welling in
the chat glad to see some regulars and
we're going to play a game some games
today or I'm going to play some games
today it will be tricky it will be
tricky to keep that writing I'm pretty
sure it was a gap very successful
recently and I'm about the 2500 mark and
this is tough to keep if you have worked
like I know I don't have any good
comparison to that I work the whole day
and don't feel particularly fresh so i
hope i hope it works out fine okay yeah
alter my possible like 20 points but
then i would need to win from here from
that very lofty rating okay i hope
stream works fine technically today yeah
i've requested a game i did not get one
hmm i don't get a game that's that's
cool what about current events I have
not checked Oh geary loss to Hari
Krishna today didn't have any time to
check this and I on OBT Cornelius ok so
i don't get a game I don't get a game
what the beep yeah I did not upload the
33 Blitz videos today the first time
form for a long time for the first time
for for a long time I simply did not
have the time to record stuff the
weekend was started getting haga that is
that possible yeah but I've got white
which is statistically almost impossible
ok I don't know what is playing b6 no
place this one ok i don't really not out
form some crazy opening and not crazy
but i don't want the banco and stuff
rather have full control en the maroc
see by this is very nice yeah this is
some an absolute main line here for
black Bishop will come to c 6 and so on
I should have played one b3f yeah there
is some point to that it's funny he
always plays 1b3 if you are not familiar
with this
they're so remark by cat rocket move
that is got problems with the chat
screen you can actually pop our to the
chat into a separate window maybe this
is an option in the honor youtube on the
YouTube page this is how I do it all of
the time I have the have a separate
window for the chat okay I'm trying to
get something going here with a three
and before I have a soft spot for taking
with the C porn in those structures
which is usually not the right way to go
usually you take with the e pawn and
play against them is have a pawn at the
end but I have very good experience with
this kind of kind of play okay he's now
sacrificing that porn I don't want to
take it I don't want to take the pawn
my ideas Queen f1 to go be should be
five and I came didn't react to that I'm
not sure that he had to but at least
that was my idea taking the pawn I did
not like giving him too much too much
play I thought a thought okay but this
is this is fine for him probably let's
double vision perk him I wanted to
double only see if I'll maybe um now i'm
not sure if i get the rating restored
ever cheetah has reported successfully
probably it happened once at least that
I got it got it bag it stuffy I mean
white is more comfortable but it is a
very solid position for black wonder
what he's doing okay he wants to
probably play King age 7 and King age 7
and Bishop to h6
you
now he wants to play a for I guess so
i'm going to prevent that a for this
before winning a piece and now yeah i
can try f4 here f4 and possibly five
yeah the maroc see by this an opening
where I have a really good score with
white just kind of being in control
positions it's something that I really
enjoy you can still screw up quite
clearly but i think i'm i'm in a good
shape here the idea is possibly 50 k
equals back i can go if I've now then he
will retreat it looks like the right
move though yeah i think i'd go for it
okay an interesting ideas to take on c5
open and try to try to keep the shout
out but I shot a shot off he still
cannot move okay can move the Knight to
d7
okay that's not entirely clear
hmm i don't like the rook on the
fourth-ranked thought i would like to
take on c5 i put the bishop on c4 this
would be cool let's put this back okay
now if five is threatened so I'm going
to take it and maybe how came maybe he
will just take with the B pawn no this
was my idea but he has f5 this is the
thing and the check here yeah that
wasn't very convincing let's block this
hog is a character of the book play b3
win yeah sometimes it is win with be
three but not not most of the time okay
so he wants to put the Queen somewhere
damn sorry my voice is a bit a bit off
yeah I cannot do much here time morning
Jim oh my such an ambitious player all
right this is I don't think this can be
good and cheeks just Bishop d3 hangers
ok now look aged 8 is coming ok so I
have to take it Oh check that wasn't so
good why did he go damn he could have
played Queen tags no it's made screen f7
made or Bishop e2 and made to [ __ ] ok
what is that little presence keep a
friendship alive or something like that
very nice black resigns so let's see
that a couple of question can i play the
Queens gambit accepted I get the
opportunity I can try and there's a
question with from Lawrence lifts a
looking at the slab as black is there
particularly good line for black after
d4 d5 c4 c6 9339 f6 III know there isn't
a particularly good line we can put this
on the board real quickly Lawrence this
question here here there is no
particularly good line the Mariners okay
you can play Bishop f5 but you have to
be ready to sacrifice a pawn after that
which is here like be 795 oops certify
the sim is a problem so here you would
have to play something very aggressive
this this pawn sacrifice so it's a bit
tricky the thing is if you want to play
the capture here the capture line my
recommendation is to take him to get
similar position and this is getting
interesting yeah white can go a 44 and
so on I think this is an interesting
line the most common move is e 4 then be
5 & a 4 p-4 and this is this is
interesting also for black I would you
ever do them if you want to avoid 9383
okay next game
yeah today's also the final round of the
US Championships I think a very
interesting event is also coming up I
think they I'm not sure about that I
might be wrong maybe you guys know it
there is this blitz tournament where the
top three finishers from the US Open
Championships play Kasparov um um this
is a very cool event it's probably later
later that that week gain started okay
playing promised here with black playing
a different line here with g6 yeah the
QA of openings instead of blitz chess
this is some basically what John Watson
is doing honest ask the master is it ask
the matter I cannot pronounce that it's
Tuesday it's on Tuesdays ask ask the
master probably as is the name i'm not
mistaken and no I'm not covering the
Norway chess or the US Chamber I simply
have no time at the moment absolutely no
time to today i may add so many things
on my plate haven't even eaten properly
which is probably not a good idea
okay so um here i'm happy with my bishop
pair but he still has a very nice
position if i go Bishop 6 35 i think i
have to attack the center do it like
that you know I've gotten control over
the d5 square and this shouldn't be
shouldn't be too bad i wonder if i
should go f4 f4 is an interesting option
and now it gets very very attractive
actually or i'm not sure it gets very
interesting at least let's go f4 and now
if I sacrifice on age three how is it
defending against that okay let show me
show me there's a question what am i
doing at the moment besides chest
nothing else I'm basically doing chest
but have some some other things to to
take care off at the moment and they
simply they simply take time and it's
it's couldn't even manage and I said to
to do the Blitz videos okay I wanted to
go rook to h5 hmm maybe that's not
working him
Bishop f4 yeah here I have Brooke age
five and I thought to no no no no look I
traviesa Bishop f4 in fact okay okay but
what is it what is the what can he do
here actually if I go f3 he goes Quincy
floor maybe hmm check King in the corner
hmm it isn't so clear actually and rock
h5 this Bishop f4 hmm strange i wonder
if i have time here maybe I can just
take it's a bit tricky at time wise i
cannot spend ages
he can go Queen f3 maybe that could save
save the day yeah I can take every now
and have thi have a couple of pawns hmm
i don't like that
okay I keep the Queen on the board maybe
that was wrong
quite tough the bad thing is if you have
that that high rating I a mean one loss
against this kind of players like 30
points down yeah it's really really
brutal okay so what's here look aged
five okay i'm just taking this night you
fall I was thinking we should be fibers
also move about rook age five also
strong rook h5 this one okay
ok put this here that can be helpful so
the Queen moves that I've f3 no I don't
watch Game of Thrones not because I mean
really I didn't have it didn't didn't
somehow catch that the start of all
these things all this series and I
really didn't have no idea what's going
on shoot doesn't it doesn't look so
convincing here
well I don't see a good continuation
here hmm yeah I somehow let him out of
this let em escape time morning I see
like a couple of points though I
actually have four points for all this
interesting
four pawns it's not bad what kind of
time I have 40 seconds a night it's not
very stable this is the problem really o
Queen d7 and okay didn't find dad
Joe
check okay and now I'm pretty okay
everything with my pawns 19 seconds okay
he's essentially hoping for the time
haha what a shame that certainly had a
good position here this game check all
rights very annoying and very annoying
loss wow this is the kind of game that
sucks air you ever have a win probably
somewhere and that didn't didn't do it
okay so let's see if I can get that
that's raining back but it is stuff here
at that dilemma you simply cannot drop
winning positions like this even the end
game is just better for black a lot
better for luck okay anyway anyway as
such too long for the win in the middle
game which was certainly certainly there
somewhere somewhere around here black is
just winning but I didn't finish it off
I didn't finish it off I had d5 as
stronger now anyway so I hope I get a
new game but it's very slow i think
indeed many many young people do watch
the US Championship and it's a nice
tournament right
it's a really strong event with the
three two thousand seven hundred guys on
ya d 5 is strongly in this position it
basically wins now yeah that would have
won the game here d 5 assists over and
why can resign the Danish gambit I can
absolutely sure that I will never play
the Danish gambit it's just nonsense
anyway I don't get a game I don't get
games okay i also will join the 3-minute
pool I cannot wait around all day here
and don't get any games what's really
strange starting okay we've got a three
minute game so I have to be a bit a bit
quicker here than usual but otherwise it
seems I have problems getting a game I
was someone placed the albuns don't have
that too often that people have such a
strong masochistic site Bishop to e6
okay okay okay
there are not there are no results yet
for the final round of the US
Championships
yeah a three is good and bioshock
schweitzer says against the album's it's
true but this line is also good
yeah this is so leading to an edgy game
the porn down for pretty much nothing so
I can also i can do this on probably
keeping the pawn yeah I've upon up and
have compensation that's good yeah I'm
actually pretty awful opponent in three
minutes if I take it seriously because
usually i only play that for that three
minute madness form and when i'm playing
some crazy crazy stuff on purpose so my
rating is far too low
yeah I'm not sure that the album's
gambit is losing but it is it is pretty
bad
and you're taking here is probably not a
great idea on d5 no I'll just play play
normal stuff or what is he doing here
but should be 3 or what's the point ok
and go them I wonder if we could have
taken on c6 maybe but this is still not
a threat i have two should be 5 at the
end
you
time warning and this is kind of kind of
crazy this position he definitely did a
good job in confusing me
yeah if I would take three minutes
seriously and play it off and I would
definitely be above 2,400 there's no big
question then okay so this is still kind
of confusing amazing I have no time this
is bloody three miniatures
and 20 26 seconds check check check
check check generally he will escape
with a draw check check check rome drama
ah shoot ok but ok the time was a big
problem and I was a big problem ok so
every five minutes all three minute game
whoo so let's see yeah color should have
won the game I was like a complete win
have to move 10 but tough tough yeah but
it's tough today and this really i mean
the bid the server is actually packaging
we've got many people on so i got
another another three minute game you
have to be very quick in three minute
don't know if I have to do that but I
don't want to calculate stuff and keep
it simple okay that's that's good but
annoying twin see two days before
hanging ok I would like to make sure
that be five is not coming so do i play
I'll go with this yeah there are many
people on the server but they don't seem
to play they seem to mostly watch the US
Championships broadcast I didn't get a
whoops oops didn't see that one coming
there's a question will i do a banter
banter blitz on so soon i don't know i
usually do the the simultaneous displays
for for the asus eee and i think it's
good fun so there's nothing planned in
particular I'm preventing Bishop e6e
because of rugby three
okay okay I guess I'll take keep it
simple oh no I don't want to blend the e
Phi it's not a good idea let's not
blunder a central pawn ok let's go there
ok I cannot go nite c4 unfortunately but
what is this point he wants to trade I
guess rugby one is a bit lame and like
this one possibly for b3 here maybe we
should be six of this one ok p 3 there
is rook c3 I see that now
time warning
Roxy 3 I can still just move the Queen
mighty cannot take yet as a a designing
still not so easy to play this position
him like a soul so active
and it's tough we cannot take b3 and not
sure what is movers maybe some improving
moves on the other hand it's not clear
how dangerous be takes a force you can
still recapture this and it's still very
active I would like to get to his king
air with Queen age five but the night is
hanging on d 2 okay here i was thinking
you i have some something active not
sure this is good but the times the
times oh I shoot maybe I'm still okay I
didn't see any of that but check eyes
got this chick instead of mate i don't
i'm not sure which i'd check check
probably not check check wants to play
on time of course we're in typical stuff
check check check check check check
check check check check
checkmate yes yeah okay that was good
those are the ones that I really like
okay we let seem game started okay got
another three minute game I'm trying for
both but it doesn't work it simply
doesn't work ok let's see a three-minute
chess I can try something a little bit
more crazy at times where's that no idea
let's play the Schliemann okay with
Creed III let's do it like this I can do
this it's better than it looks which is
probably it okay coming down that really
that great i have a hard time to believe
that I mean so wyd can play that so to
leave it is it really bad for me doesn't
look too bad
hmm and we'd like to trade his queen
there of course
Bishop d7 but he can take a plane 95
which looks very shaky now I probably
get killed now but I couldn't see who
this one okay and this I didn't think
was so dangerous surprising taking a 95
that was a lot better I think okay so
what is the point if I takes I'm losing
c7 okay
okay I'm just too slowly and I'm just
not used to three minute
it's a bit slow here castling by hand
but you have to work with what you yeah
what year would you have not happy about
that but okay I rook takes 26 now as a
threat time morning
hmm interesting move I cannot take the
point yeah cool cool play have I schema
here or what's whatever however you
might want to pronounce it yeah it's got
queen age 3 here this is going to be
probably too tough I can't a key for I
think I can take a form and if I get it
Luke age 8 i'm not in such bad shape
anyway check
yeah I don't see how I'm losing
Hampshire he might get the draw of
course but he also wow wow okay mmm what
now hey just teachers had to dump this
bloody porn check check oh yeah nice
nice stuff I can check check okay yeah
Neville's knives f3 yeah my king was
kind of unstable of course in it and
it's a lot lots of it is actually
gambling in this time control this is
more bullet than than anything three
minute let's see I still have both
requests our I think but both same gain
started another three minute yeah anyway
it's it's good fun anyway so let's see
what I can do here I got Queens gambit
accepted her request so let's go
forgotten how this line goes I think
something like this I think something
like this but I don't quite remember
it's not madness I'm still playing
relatively solid openings him come on ok
I'll look chicks I have no idea maybe
book Jakes yeah he has got some some
activity of absolutely I wonder if
Bishop takes you three ism one not the
night might come to you for him don't
quite like this and let's go back Bishop
c4 is possibly a move okay
hmm that was a big of a quick decision I
should have thought about a moment
thought for a moment about this I really
want to play this move and but ok so hmm
so he lets me take on e on d4 Knight f6
is a moon I don't know if I really want
to allow that it will get will be
chaotic as usual
check yeah objectively now Black is
winning but it three minutes for
anything can happen I've got a a couple
of pawns actually six I got two pawns
him
it's a question what my opinion is by
Carlton can't win against Geary um
interesting question I think there's
definitely one point that Geary's
preparation is really excellent and
quite awful i think he manages to get a
game that's very difficult to even keep
playing and he has a good good knack of
finding those those lines that make it
very difficult to to play not only play
for win but towards awesome to have some
kind of idea how to how to even win
because if there is some kind of idea
cards are very often well you'll find it
but he simply doesn't get those kind of
positions against and gets give you that
much so Bishop here and one point is
certainly not to be underestimated that
Giri is not afraid of cards and I think
he's just he doesn't have there's no
special psychological thing in play time
morning he just plays it like a game and
I mean like a normal game and it's not
particularly afraid and this is
definitely helpful check
and i would like to somehow use this
this bishop here don't see away though
check oh I didn't see that more coming
absolutely not check but he didn't see
this one coming check Bishop age five
check check check check check one what
the heck check and check it wasn't the
best continuation but it was at least
somewhat easy to play check check check
check it's bloody quick wait for fans
fun wow you really caught on who I don't
think I could take on could have taken
on g3 there was there was an issue there
yeah giving us one the very first game
he played against Carlton when he was
still very young and after that he at
least never lost one tons of drawers
okay game started I guess it's a three
minute show I mean I don't mind but I
should have played before actually try
to try to get something else here for
for this but okay if they play at five
I'm going to do something drastic little
three minute madness flavor hmm night
two before you want to play I guess okay
Ailee now move on move on wow talk about
a complicated name I have the most
beautiful porn structure definitely
isn't that great has a fantastic pawn
structure really fantastic stuff but
anyway what to do
yeah listen there are slight doubts yeah
this is so great in the chat I really
wonder why yeah this is probably not
from the Russian school of chess I have
a double pole and isolated pawn a triple
porn and we know what the worst part is
he actually plays well and we really
don't like that the opponent playing
well it's not a good idea okay really
not looking great him what is that
actually I'm I am I poor you know he
wants to trade down to an ending you are
no fun mr. LOL on something he just
takes my pawns it's just a very bad
ending very little chance is actually
even if it would play really badly it's
a hard too hard to see to how to imagine
how you could screw it up
really difficult to imagine very bad
time morning it's to a loss what can you
do now I know what I five okay actually
didn't make any progress for like 20
moves almost but then I was just was too
much and he played this quite well yeah
you played this quite well or she Elano
something could be female 11,000
three-minute games that's quite a bit
yep a big Fork
would I consider to join or three-minute
on streams I don't know and five minute
on my regular videos I don't know if
that's a good idea it's tough to really
do something in three minute games in
terms of commentary it's just a lot
easier in five minute but I couldn't get
any any games going to them hmm ok this
is a good good Latvian gambit yeah you
have no development and your position is
just full of weaknesses am I still get
tempted to play it yeah bye bye you guys
in the chat and I absolutely I shouldn't
do it I really shouldn't ok tip what the
joke of a position you have absolutely
tons of weaknesses I it's a completely
unplayable position now Bishop h5 and I
forgot Knight f6 yeah what the heck and
let's take it check wow really you're
going to sacrifice everything here yeah
maybe maybe it tries to sacrifice two
rooks and made me which probably will
work check this is very likely winning
from white I mean my position is such a
joke you can even sacrifice two rooks
Wow
this one Wow
check it's like dodging bullets and
probably unsuccessfully he could have
taken me four with check and that just
would have won instead that he allows me
this check here what the heck King it to
be sure before we win what check I'm mes
gotta have three and still doesn't lose
of course this is so unnecessary it's
hard to even fight words for that that
he allowed all that does he actually
have a check not not quiet
time money he has a chick here on the
six ring yeah let's do this first that
it also gives me the age 5 square queen
h1 can check how we can just take the
rook ah I didn't see that one Oh what
did what did whoops food check damn yeah
I know maybe you've learned us the Queen
now I've been taking the queen with
night at five very unlikely though check
yeah he just marches the point I mean it
was kind of a kind of funny that he
actually allowed something to happen Jed
since i'm actually promoting here right
check it's kind of a big fun funny joke
I know he has his lucky if I would be at
what second plan for fits on time yeah
it's a three minute pool okay I'm going
to play like one more year yeah it
seemed like hope chest it's just losing
chest at salette VN gambit you are lost
on move to it's just what it is check
now I'm even totally lost here the whole
way even though it was completely
ridiculous that he allowed it okay queen
bee tuna actually wins but it
whatever yeah the Latvian is really
extreme and it's just like you're lost
on move to plain and simple and yeah
it's a bit too much I mean even if even
if or g5 or crap like that is probably
better and this is already bad okay I
try to really should get in game game
started okay it gropes attack let's do
it against grandmaster Novick here see
for energy for its that sets a cool
combination this is actually not that
bad for white the g5 porn is rather
rather annoying to play against
shouldn't be underestimated the elephant
gambit is better than the Latvian
because it doesn't doesn't weaken the
king that much it's also completely
incorrect of course but then they let
viene also getting checkmated
maybeee for is a strong move now could
be but it three minute just you have to
be quick and 92 is actually giving away
g5 so I don't want to do that this isn't
so bad right or am I wrong I've got some
weaknesses to play against and his
bishops don't do that much
hmm it looks actually quite okay you
might take it also take here let's take
this one
mmm we should you I cannot move it I
probably have to take our then critiques
is a bit of an annoyance it really is
mmm how to do this here
94
what Quincy one is made okay
there was a question and said if I hit
do smoke we don't ever did or whatever
no i don't i don't smoke at all anymore
and this is i'm happy about it and i
don't really believe much in doing any
kind of drug time morning including
alcohol I mean I drink beer on occasion
but this is really what it is ok so I'm
a piece up here but it's also somewhat
tricky qinglin team only one isn't
exactly safe I think he and probably
does have some connection issue known ok
I'm happy that he has taken stuff
simplify a little bit black Brazil yeah
it's probably not amused against g4 okay
anyway I hope you enjoyed the show today
was a little bit different I didn't get
five minute games I think even though we
have many strong players on mostly they
were watching the US Championships okay
we have a couple of results then let me
see Robson Nakamura is a draw that means
that probably now can we were qualified
for that bleach map blitz stuff against
Kasparov okay anyway oh that's that's
interesting Oh in the women's
championship let's have a look at their
abrahamian was leading he lost she lost
to his war on this opens the door for a
couple of possibilities how did she lose
and so quickly
wow I guess the kid totally totally
killed her strategically home while she
got totally wiped out wow I don't even
know what this means I think probably
Paquita is doing it now she has to draw
against crush to get the title what is
that I'm sorry that's not part of the
show I you know but I'm kind of curious
in well that's a very sharp position
watching
wow it's hard to tell that's hard to
tell I don't like white skink position
that sets clear wait to play though ok I
want to analyze it in in much depth but
I was just curious to see that that this
win was already in by his war on she was
a huge underdog against taught em but
very nice very nice ok i hope you
enjoyed the show a little bit of a
detour at the end ok bye bye I'll be on
next week next monday that is may the
second i believe yeah thanks for
watching bye bye